madame la Première ministre la
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
voulue par le président de la République
a répondu dimanche à la question que
vous lui aviez posé le 9 décembre
dernier
à travers 146 propositions cette
convention citoyenne à exprimé très
clairement et très précisément
sa volonté de voir évoluer notre cadre
légal actuel et je tiens ici à saluer le
travail remarquable grâce à l'appui du
Conseil économique social et
environnementale de ces 184 citoyens
tirés au sort et représentatif de la
diversité de notre société
184 citoyens de tous âges et de toute
condition qui ont accepté de consacrer
durant 27 journées durant 9 sessions de
participer à une réflexion collective
sur ce sujet majeur ils ont affirmé avec
force la nécessité de renforcer les
soins palliatifs pour tous et partout
sur le territoire et ils ont exprimé une
demande forte à une très large majorité
c'est à dire plus de 76% que soit
autorisé en France l'aide active à
mourir sur certaines conditions comme
par exemple
l'incurabilité de la maladie le
pronostic vital engagé les souffrances
réfractaires et la volonté réitérer du
malade sans oublier la clause de
conscience des soignants alors madame la
Première ministre je souhaitais tout
simplement vous demander quelle suite
entendez-vous donner
à ce message fort qui a été exprimé par
cette très belle convention citoyenne